en el último vídeo y hablamos un poco
sobre lo que era crear una empresa una
fábrica de cupcakes y estamos hablando
de una gran inversión por eso al menos
voy he hecho una hoja de cálculo en
excel para poder poder checar esto y de
hecho lo pueden descargar en khan
academy punto org diagonal downloads
diagonal cupcakes punto xls y si
terminan hasta downloads van a poder ver
todo lo que se puede descargar pero
bueno voy a empezar añadiendo más poco a
poco les animó a utilizar esto excel
fundamentalmente hará los cálculos
matemáticos que hicimos en el último
vídeo
digamos que la inversión en la fábrica
ya después de hablar con contratistas y
demás resulta que es de un millón cien
mil dólares que la capacidad anual de
los cupcakes es de un millón y cada
cupcake cuesta 1.05 dólares y bueno aquí
podemos utilizar números más chistosos
porque excel va a hacer los cálculos por
mí así que digamos que el precio de ese
ese y que el precio de venta por cupcake
es de dos dólares bueno en realidad
puede ser cualquier número no aquí en
esta en esta entrada le podemos poner el
valor que queramos y abajo podemos
ponerle el número de cupcakes que
podemos vender en cada año
en este contexto esto es lo que tenemos
de ingresos no al menos hasta cierto
cierto tiempo de operación y bueno si
calculamos aquí tenemos dos millones de
ingresos pero si le cambiamos a que cada
cupcake lo vendemos en 150 entonces sólo
tengo un millón 500 mil así que de hecho
esto hace los cálculos inmediatamente si
yo cambio por ejemplo el número de
cupcakes que venda digamos que ahora
vendo 500 mil
todo lo calcula de forma adecuada todo
lo calcula de forma adecuada y en todos
estos escenarios me dicen cuáles son mis
ingresos operativos si nos vamos un
poquito más abajo me dice 'me mi
capacidad de utilidad
esto es cuántos cupcakes vendí y
divididos entre cuántos podría producir
y en este caso el 50 por ciento
también tenemos la rentabilidad
económica que son mis ingresos
operativos divididos entre mi inversión
inicial ok entonces esto es 275 mil
dividido entre 1.1 millón y eso me da
este número en este último vemos que
realmente como como dueño de la fábrica
de cupcakes yo puedo cambiar el precio
en este caso no me convenía de este
precio pero obviamente si yo pongo un
precio más bajo a lo mejor más gente va
a querer comprarlo aunque a veces la
gente al ponerle tuvo un precio alto a
un producto la gente lo desea más porque
quieren presumir solo a sus amigos o ver
ven que sí que que es muy caro es porque
es muy bueno entonces en general uno un
precio bajo implica que más gente va a
comprar entonces aquí podemos figurar
varias combinaciones por ejemplo si aquí
le cambio el precio y cuántos cupcakes
vendo bueno en este caso yo tenía una
pérdida verdad así que si yo vendo a lo
mejor cada cupcake en 1.75 y vendo 700
mil cupcakes bueno apenas estoy como
casi en el equilibrio así que vamos a
venderlo en 1.85 aquí en esta situación
ya tenemos una rentabilidad del 5% y
bueno como realmente es una gran
inversión de un millón con 100.000
queremos asegurarnos de que entendemos
los escenarios de precios y de ventas en
fin por eso hacemos esto en excel aquí
puse todas las la hago vanos varias
combinaciones de gm voy a esta parte de
la hoja de cálculo les invito a que
jueguen con esto porque realmente es muy
muy interesante te muestra cosas muy
sencillas de negocios y de análisis si
estás en prepa o en secundaria lo mejor
esto puede ser divertido te puede ayudar
un proyecto de ciencia pero si vas a
montar un negocio o quieres analizar
esto lo puedes hacer de muchas formas de
hecho si ves los vídeos de
probabilidades todos tienen cosas que
ver con procesos corazón y demás puedes
analizar el negocio en una hoja de excel
y pues a lo mejor ganar un proyecto de
ciencias o un proyecto de matemáticas en
fin lo que quiero aquí es ver cuál es mi
rentabilidad económica así que realmente
estoy dividiendo las ganancias
operativas entre la inversión inicial
así que depende de distintos precios
puedo cambiar ese valor verdad así que
esto es a lo mejor un poquito difícil de
visualizar así que lo digo lo dibujé
holográfica en tres dimensiones en una
superficie así que como ven si yo cargo
280 por cada cupcake y viendo sólo
300.000 aquí tenemos este punto esta
curva de hecho es una curva nula verdad
esta es una curva del equilibrio así que
cualquier punto en esta curva estoy en
el equilibrio es decir no gano ni le
pierda así que si yo vendo 280
cupcake y sólo vendo 300.000 no voy a
ganar dinero estoy en el punto de
equilibrio así que si vendo por ejemplo
160 y cada cupcake y vendo 900 mil
también estoy en el punto de equilibrio
ok
así que este es mi mi punto de mi curva
de punto de equilibrio y esto es lo que
quiero evitar todo en esta parte es
negativa verdad de acuerdo con la ley la
leyenda de esta dice que está entre
menos 50% y 0 por ciento de rentabilidad
así que aquí pierdo dinero y lo colorear
y así no estuviera en excel pero si yo
cobro 160 por cupcake y vendo 400.000
unidades voy a tener una rentabilidad
negativa así que aquí esto de cualquier
forma es divertido de mirarlo y los
invito a que jueguen con él esto de
hecho muestra una forma interesante y
solo lo interesante y sofisticado que
puede ser esto no cómo crear un negocio
aquí estamos solo variando los
parámetros pero imagínense si empiezo a
cambiar todos los demás así que
digamos que cuando vengo ya
al al puesto digamos quiero que todo el
pueblo conozca mis cupcakes porque
pienso que son deliciosos y se van a dar
cuenta de ello entonces también he
aprendido de algunas compañías de
cigarros que si pongo nicotina en los
cupcakes bueno la gente va a empezar a
sentirse adicta a ellos así que lo que
puedo hacer es digamos déjenme cambiar
el precio voy a ponerlo en unos 75 y eso
es algo muy barato pero verdad pero de
hecho por el momento no hay productores
de cupcakes digamos y que yo tengo una
venta enorme de un millón de unidades
así que estoy haciendo 200 mil dólares
al año y tengo una rentabilidad del 18
por ciento y estaría muy feliz con eso
verdad estoy
estoy vendiendo todos mis cómics así que
qué pasa si yo elevó un poquito el
precio digamos aquí tenemos una utilidad
del 100% verdad y esto tiene mucho
sentido porque hay hay hay gente que
quiere los cupcakes y ya no puedo
producir más verdad hay mucha gente que
los quiere pero bueno si hay mucha gente
que los quiere digamos que elevó a 185
el precio y resulta entonces
estoy haciendo ahora trescientos mil
dólares al año así que esto parece ser
una buena idea ahora vamos a ver cuánta
gente estaría dispuesta a pagar por mis
cupcakes algo más caro digamos vamos a
venderlos ahora en dos dólares pero
resulta a lo mejor conviene ponerlo como
en 199 pero bueno dejémoslo así pero
resulta que ahora no vendo eso si no
vendo 950 mil es decir que hay 50 mil
personas que no están dispuestas a pagar
dos dólares pero si estarían dispuestas
a pagar un 85 bueno esto no funciona
verdad estoy vendiendo a lo mejor menos
cupcakes pero estoy dándole un un mayor
precio así que estoy obteniendo un 37%
de rentabilidad así que vamos a ponerle
ahora que lo vendemos en tres cada
cupcake y que ahora vendemos 750 mil
unidades
y bueno ahora tenemos 962 mil quinientos
ingresos y esto nos subió a 88 por
ciento de que bueno cada año de
rentabilidad así que esto es algo muy
bueno entonces a estas alturas seguro ya
estoy manejando un mercedes benz a lo
mejor y estoy en la casa más grande y
entonces otra gente dice oye todo lo que
está haciendo este hombre son cupcakes
yo también puede hacer como cake si
tengo dinero para construir una fábrica
y esto es una rentabilidad mucho mejor
que invertir en otros lugares así que
van voy a hacer también yo mi fábrica de
cupcakes es el negocio entonces aquí es
donde viene la segunda hoja de excel de
esta así que digamos que yo había
invertido un millón 1.1 millón de
dólares
déjeme a ver si puedo hacerle su min
aunque en mi capacidad es de un millón
ok que vendo en tres dólares y vendo 750
mil unidades mi costo era de 1.05 y
entonces estaba haciéndose 962 1500
después digamos que viene mi hijo imran
y también quiere ver si puede montar su
propia fábrica de cupcakes digamos que
ya vio a su papá que funciona el negocio
y demás y entonces él tiene un dinero
ahorrado entonces imagínense la
situación eres un chico que tiene dinero
quiere invertir en un negocio porque a
lo mejor ya no quiere que su papá le
esté dando el domingo no hoy y además de
todo su abuela le puede regalar algo de
dinero se lo hereda o no sé entonces él
va a invertir un millón y medio de en su
fábrica y puede producir dos millones de
cupcakes al año porque invirtió mucho
más entonces esta es una fábrica más
eficiente a lo mejor usa menos
electricidad
gasta menos crema o en congelación no se
usa más nicotina lo mejor así que el
costo de cada cupcake es menor digamos
que desde 90 centavos de dólar y
entonces decide decide cobrar 2 90 por
cupcake jaja entonces cuando el cobra
290 por cada unidad entonces todo el
mundo corre a comprar sus cupcakes
porque es una mejor oferta verdad así
que digamos que venden 500 500.000
cupcakes
y entonces yo estoy vendiendo sólo 250
mil ya tres dólares cada uno así que hay
algunas personas que todavía quieren mis
cupcakes realmente estoy casi en el
punto de equilibrio ok
solo por la introducción de imran ahora
para para beneficiar todavía a las
personas que me que consumen mis cakes
voy a subir el precio pero no tanto sino
sólo a tres dólares con diez centavos
entonces bueno esto no es una situación
muy justa se llevó todo mi negocio de
hecho quiero que se den cuenta de algo
aquí yo estaba haciendo un 88 por ciento
de rentabilidad verdad me está
devolviendo a esa cantidad de dinero
luego llega invernales a este a esta
situación y qué pasa de repente él solo
está corriendo al 25 por ciento de su
capacidad pero su rentabilidad es del 20
por ciento entonces
y bueno mi mies de rentabilidad se fue
al 1% cuando alguien empieza a ser muy
bien un negocio siempre atrae
competencia y atrae es de capacidad por
supuesto así que si hay suficiente
demanda quizás va a tener una mejor
rentabilidad por en general conforme
pasa el tiempo y empieza y mientras
sigue siendo favorable todo esto entra
más competencia y por lo pronto nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo